[Music]
it seems sometimes that tribal
disagreement has replaced conventional
rational debates we do need to start
thinking about whether or not we can
recover a shared framework of engagement
is there a need to actually recover the
idea of what truth is or perhaps that
knowledge that maybe it never existed in
the first place well tough issues and to
answer them we have three extremely
distinguished speakers on the panel
tonight on my left is Professor homi
Bhabha known to all of you I suspect as
an immensely distinguished theorist of
post colonialism and the writer of books
which I think are read sweated over and
debated by students around the world on
the left-hand side here we have Rebecca
Goldstein again a distinguished
philosopher notably so not least because
she was honored by President Obama and
novelist as well and on my right hand
side we have Hilary Lawson a very
provocative and thoughtful philosopher
who has produced what some people have
called the first non realist metaphysics
although I'm glad that I'm not the one
who has to analyze that claim in detail
homi Bhabha could I turn to you do we
still need an objective truth in your
opinion well this morning I said that
the first capital T of tribalism was
exaggerated and problematic and now I'm
gonna say that the capital T of truth is
possibly not the best way of looking at
this problem I mean there are many very
interesting theories of truth
correspondence theory discursive Theory
mimetic theory so it seems to me that
there are many theories that theories of
truth all of which respect some note
with respect a notion that is against
some against some entirely she's earned
pluralism or relativism but today when
we talk about the post truth world
I feel we are not actually talking
really about post truth we are talking
about alternative truths as indeed you
hear them now in public political
discourse when Giuliani mayor Giuliani
said famously on television truths what
is truth or indeed when in the recent
film Eichmann is scripted as having said
what is truth believe me these are not
metaphysical deep metaphysical
discussions they are precisely parts of
a war a political war to establish a
certain kind of vocabulary which speaks
to a particular political issue and
therefore I think alternative truths
gives you a sense that there is now
actually a struggle amongst various I am
honest ideologies and people want to
impose a particular view so and it
doesn't it doesn't end with Giuliani and
Trump in the Indian textbooks today when
they want to get rid of evolution of the
theory of evolution when they want to
suggest that a cancer that that cancer
remedies and cancer technologies were
all known to the Vedas that and these
are in school textbooks now I think that
is as fight a struggle over truth and
this reminds me of a statement that
Foucault once made that there may be no
universal truth but there is always an
important struggle in any particular
historical time or discourse about
trying to establish on the best evidence
and the best discourse what is true
because it's on that basis that we make
our laws we build our conventions we
think of our rules we think of our norms
so I think that one has to contest
various truths because the coz the
relationship between reality and truth
often changes death in Venice
doesn't mean the same thing as death on
the Ganges it's a very different
cultural social metaphysical and
religious phenomenon so my
feeling is that we have to think not
about consensus around truth but about
conventions and traditions of
convergence and universities and
cultural institutions and our
pedagogical of our pedagogical views and
policies are extraordinarily important
because my final thought on this we've
got to establish some interpretational
good practice that's as far as I will
put it when you oppose me when you fight
me to the ground I must be able to
recognize in the version you give of my
ideas sound fairness I don't mind if you
disagree with it I don't mind if you
exaggerate some parts rather than the
other but some form of the totality of
my argument that I can recognize and
therefore on a productive platform
respond to you must be there I call it
interpretational good practice I'm
trying to think about it and work it out
but that's where for the moment I rest
my case
well that sets up a very very
interesting idea that we'll come back to
after other opening statements the idea
of good practice in that type of debate
is clearly getting very important in
understanding whether or not we're
actually on the same in the same
framework and on the same grounds I'd
put it I think the first person to ask
what is true what is truth may have been
Pontius Pilate so whether that is a good
starting point for this debate is
slightly worrying thought but we'll get
back to that too but before they do that
let us turn next to goldstein Rebecca
the question before us is whether there
is something that can be called
objective truth and if so whether we
still have a need for it
what are your thoughts so I have to me
that the idea of truth of objective
truth is absolutely necessary I think
there's nothing very fancy about it it's
true what homie had said that we
philosophers have often put forth
alternative different what are called
different theories of truths the
correspondence theory the coherence
theory
pragmatic notions of truth I don't think
that these were actually defining truth
the good old common garden-variety truth
is built in to the act of assertion just
to assert something is to say that it's
true it goes back to why language is
important in the first place we write
one of the definitions of the
correspondence theory notion of truth
one of the definitions put forth by a
philosopher named tarski is snow is
white that proposition is true if and
only if snow is white which is
completely boring and uninteresting and
that's because truth it's just it's so
fundamental we really can't to find it
what we have argued about what we have
argued about for since the beginning of
philosophy since the beginning of being
rational creatures is a how do we
ascertain the truth so what so it's it's
our knowledge of the truth that has been
contested and you know there empiricists
there a rationalist there are those who
think emotion is important in
determining the truth those who think
it's it's it completely gets in the way
it's this is you know epistemology its
its its knowledge of truth that is the
Trulie a difficult thing
so truth to me is is is it's a very
prosaic term and when somebody tells me
they don't believe in objective true
truth I say and am I supposed to believe
what you just said and if you know if if
you if I am you've not if why should you
take what you just said seriously so
it's you know it's just a self-defeating
kind of proposition I I wonder we are if
something interesting is going on right
now and so you know more interesting
than all of these fights that we've
always had about how do we reach to this
faith important religion science all of
these you know it's art a means of
finding truth this is these are old base
that go back
no since since the ancient Greeks really
us but so what there is something new
that's happening now and as as homie had
said it's something political that has
happened and the way I I see it what has
happened it is tied in with the
tribalism it's a very interesting
phenomenon there are more things that we
do with language than simply making
assertions and Alec and ina said there
are many language games we play and one
of the things that we do in language is
that we pledge allegiance to some cause
and what has happened recently in our in
our day is that certain propositions
that have truth values and that in some
cases the truth value has been
determined by scientists by experts um
have become banners for once tried and
so for example if I tell you oh I don't
think that human activity has anything
to do with climate change I'm not
talking about climate change and I'm not
really interested in the evidence for it
I am declaring my allegiance to a
particular political coalition for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute's of arson ideas
III TV
you